هنا منذ بعض الوقت اشاره للبعض من الذين
يشرفون على اعمال رفع علاقات انه يوجد
حوالي 15 شخصا نزلوا تحت الانقاذ سالنا
الان الاشخاص ماذا يفعلون كان الجواب الى
انه بالامس كان هنالك عدد من الاصوات التي
تدلل على انه يوجد احياء داخل هذا المبنى
وتحت هذه الاسقف المنهاره ولكن قالوا منذ
بعض الوقت الى ان الاصوات
ذهبت منذ ساعات
نذهب ايضا الى النقطه الاخرى هنالك كيف هم
يرفعون هذه
الاسقف المنهاره هذا فعل هنا مبني اذا صح
التعبير على الايدي وعلى الجنود وعلى
المعاول وعلى المعدات التقليديه بالمقلب
الاخر للصوره اذا ذهبت مع المصور يعني هي
مشهديه حرب كانها
الرافعات التي ترفع الانقاض والركام هنا
سيارات الاسعاف بالمقلب الاخر هي تدخل الى
قلب المدينه على عجاله من امرها وهي هذه
العجاله ليست الان انما على مدى الساعه
والمدى يعني كل الوقت تشاهدين السيارات
تدخل وتخرج القوافل بالمقلب الاخر
للكميونات التي تنقل
الجرافات وتنقل الحفارات هنا في هذا
المبنى يعني اعد حفارات اثنين ثلاثه اربعه
اربعه في هذه الجهه الى ايضا هنا
معدات متخصصه لرفع الابنيه او لرفع الاسطح
المنعدمه كما نشاهد نذهب الى تلك النقطه
لربما ماذا يعني البعض يقول انهم يحاولون
العثور على احياء ولكن بعد هذه الايام
الاربعه نعلم اذا كان هنالك من احياء
البعض يقول كما اشرت معك الى خمسه عشر
مفقودا لا زالوا تحت الانقاذ في هذا
المبنى